[Music]
you like
boats this is captain pewdiepie of the
lt fukushima we're rolling out
out of my way cleveland cleveland what
are you
cleveland oh my god yo
i got look at this thing so they updated
the game they got
airplanes which i want to play later
because i'm actually decent at it
goddammit cleveland
but now you can play with this giant ass
warship oh i'm shooting someone see i
know what i'm doing
this is like giving a baby a machine gun
i don't know what i'm doing with this
but the developers were like here you go
felix cleveland
puffed off cleveland are you really
grinding my gears cleveland
oh well done cleveland spotted
six kilometers away splashes in six
seconds
come on what is that tiny little boat
get out of here
they're really nuking that tiny poor
little boat i feel bad
that is nowhere close we gotta aim like
here
yeah submarine missiles
gosh oh they're on to me ah
i'm in the dead zone back up
this is normal planes i mean boats what
am i
we're supposed to be on fire trust me i
know i know
no i have one
what i did
my torpedoes are working don't worry
this uh siren thing that's normal
yeah you just gotta dodge these missiles
no another egg
ah okay
hey all right i'll take it
[Music]
all right let's switch to airplane i
clearly don't know what i'm doing
fukushima all right so if you download
the game with my link in the description
it's free it's not for any console you
get the profits
the swedish beautiful my god
oh my god the sweden plane
sweden's so good country made we made
plane
the la kobe let's do this
oh look at this so last video
i said the vikings had tambourines in
their airplane no i was wrong
they had flutes
oh you hear that in the skies you run
you run from your planes enemy inside
your eyes is mine boy he has no idea
felicia well i'm gonna say it
you're dead felicia dead
oh felicia oh she has swedish plane i
can't kill felicia i'm sorry felicia
i apologize i apologize for nothing for
you dying felicia
good night sweet felicia i mean bye
felice
i did it all wrong why are you not dead
ah she doesn't know she doesn't know
about the swedish
uh you may have swedish plane but you
don't have swedish skill mother
oh they just died
cool all right let's get some air
did i get a kill for that i what i did
everything
all right look at this fool oh he's
flying towards me god he's doing the
thing
what are you doing what is he doing
damn this plane is good actually
oh give me that
oh oh you don't know about the swedish
maneuvers
the swedish should barrow row why is my
landing gear out
underwater monkey learn to spell monkey
you dumb monkey are you so dead watch
this oh no it's going to crash into the
mountain
nah nah the trees are on my side
i don't think so buddy they always try
and suicide [ __ ] japanese
god damn it don't do it again
i hate that
fine that's okay because i don't have
one swedish blade
i got dudes with his brain i got two
plagues two [ __ ]
come on i gotta win i'm third come on
why is nvidia roasting me i don't want a
safe moment of death
come on come on stick kill steal oh
hit without the aim i'm shooting right
at this [ __ ]
why are you flying into mountain you
can't fly in mountain all right he's
dead
he's dead
oh that's hilarious what an idiot he
doesn't know about the mountain oh
you're dead
that's okay because i have three yeah
this is actually the best one because
it's tiny the smaller the better
that's what everyone says all the time
he doesn't know
he doesn't know say it in the comments
he doesn't know oh gold
you think you can out maneuver me
all right maybe you can whatever
oh critical hit are you going to cry now
that's [ __ ] god damn it we lost
stop roasting me nvidia it doesn't count
it doesn't count we're just warming up
trust me
so yeah they upgraded the hangers
there's they upgrade a ton of stuff in
the game
they have a new engine 6.0 it looks much
better you can tell
check out the game it's free it's fun i
like it
if you want to die by swedish man go go
right ahead ah
there's too many of them we should back
up sun tzu said that
the greatest warlord of all time all
right i'm following the protocol
no you know what i said that they're
great
oh nuclear look he plays with a
controller
cringe quote again sun tzu you're dead
end quote ah come on he killed himself
god damn it idiot oh you're dead
oh you know what that smells like
what [ __ ] felicia dude you're so dead
why are you still playing
oh oh felicia i don't think so
see the problem here felicia's are you
still there
no felicia oh dude felicia give up
give up oh that was sick felicia you can
oh my engine is out my engine is out
that's fine i don't need an engine to
fly
plane you know who said that me i said
that
look at this we're colliding with style
you know who said that
bus light year yeah save that nvidia
felicia i hope you're watching this
video and you're crying
oh look at one more kale please
oh my god i'm a god i'm too good at this
game there's snow i'm ready to go pro
now
oh can we can we i don't have an engine
but can we
oh my god i hit him commander's gonna go
i can't
fly please come on i can still do it i
can still fight
i can i can still fight
felicia
oh critical it's my kill it's my kim
how is he staring so much
oh you idiot it's fine i can fly with
one plane
uh wing they only
goddamn japanese oh oh look
who it is well where will if it isn't
felicia
bye felicia
i did the thing yeah don't try to shoot
me while you're dead
that's illegal
ah they barely i hate them i hate them
so much
stop driving into me you got that
japanese bulls yeah
look at those medals i have one game
that i won that i shot before
so i'll just show that really quick so
you can show them that i'm really good
yeah baby
oh my god i'm a god i'm the best double
kill that's so cool
look triple
birthday professional sienna i'm fine
triple care baby oh no
yo that was sick
hey hey yeah
gorgeous have you ever seen a free game
look this good
i know there's only one tuber simulator
but otherwise
let's switch to tanks but not just any
tanks okay
brofist tank mother flippin brofist tank
use the download link in the description
doesn't matter if you're older new
player
come in check out street sign m10a
it has ammo it has cuspida
uh it can shoot uh-huh i like how they
gave me like
the max of everything and i still suck
swedish lasagna camouflage nice i forgot
about that
all right here we go hey what are you
doing
why do we always get the worst teammates
stop shooting
what are you oh my god
this is why the camouflage is so good
because you can barely see me because of
my color
i come from the trees i brought you the
bees look
we're gonna pull a sneaky or a snake
tank
sun tzu said that oh yes
oh nice
ah no with ricocheting
oh critical
you're dead stop running i'm a fish
sun tzu said all right you can't hit
yeah i'm good at this game
now that was amazing oh another one
you barely see him oh he just died
whoa
uh nuke whoa i hit him
die please just die just die hit his
wheels
yeah yeah yeah
how is he undamaged
bro i'm top of the leaderboard i'm
literally winning
you need help there buddy
you're welcome teddy i saved your life
teddy
say thanks tebby if you see this youtube
video teddy you better say that oh [ __ ]
i was a
teddy you distracted me i'm dead now
i'm fine honestly i'm fine this happens
all the time
undamaged
it doesn't look good for the swede
what repair repair repair there's
another one
ah yo repair
come on you can swedes do something
i'm alive okay okay okay
okay okay okay no i lost the airplane
thing
oh oh i see you
oh oh what is happening
oh hey come on come on come on
no dang it
ah bro i'm when i'm top of the
leaderboard that was amazing
holy [ __ ] dude oh my poor swedish
brethren
they got that headache jesus
tokyo drift over here all right where
are those [ __ ]
oh my god dude i i uh
uh this is my best game i'm on fire i
can't be stopped
bro i got six kills i'm a tank destroyer
let's go maybe
maybe tanky not bad after all hell yeah
hell yeah that was amazing dude let's
try the japanese airplanes
because the japanese were good in the
war yeah i want the sizes of the weebs
now
you can tell the skies looks better and
different this time all right let's see
how the japanese planes hold up
that was not a voice crack that was just
my war they're worrying me
oh the japanese
[Music]
you're dead dude you're dead
come on
oh my god what did i just i i did that
on purpose that was the japanese tactic
my engines out my engines out oh no
come on flying to me please explain to
me
oh that's so anticlimactic dude let me
fill it in my mouth
you really think the vikings had
airplanes come on [ __ ] she doesn't know
right in the comments he doesn't know
oh he didn't even know come on
oh you're a tough cookie
i'm actually fine he doesn't know that
was like one of those samurai battles
where they strike the sword
and you can't all right let me do my god
damn it
this is a team rocket league again
all right let's finish this with some
swedish airplane you know my mom used to
play a swedish
thing and i said it last video but i
didn't show the photo so it's i've added
the photo
which one was that like one of these
damn
i can't fly that that's too complicated
let's go with the brofist plane
yeah yeah happy 2021. can't wait
thank you yeah isn't that cool i'm so
jealous but at the same time i know you
get really motion sick and i
i wouldn't be able to do it i'm happy
with war thunder thank you very much
what if we kissed in the brofist plane
yeah yeah brother's plane
oh no i lost my bro face i got one it's
all right
all right download war thunder it's a
really fun game and it's free it's out
on every console
playstation 4 5 6 7 eight
xbox pc check out the new updates if
you're an older new player
if you use the link you get the brofist
plane the pewdiepie tank all of that
shabbato
see you in game gamers thanks for
watching subscribe
look at graph brofist